bonjour monsieur vous êtes ici
tiens c'est un week end de pâques en
costumes et perruques
durant deux jours la citadelle de
besançon replonge dans son passé et se
remettent alors de vos ventes
c'est un peu notre lancement de saison
est donc aujourd'hui l'idée c'est de
revivre un petit peu là la vie du
monument la vie des xviie xviiie siècle
et donc cette année on propose la
thématique dollar du paraître et du
costume à cette époque dans la chapelle
saint-etienne les tenues portées sous le
règne du roi-soleil côtoient celles qui
s'en inspirent comme ce fourreau créé
par une jeune styliste bisontine
j'ai travaillé sur un bouton âge pour
vraiment entrer la royauté du poids une
des boutons or et du coup j'étais un
jacquard bleu cobalt avec de l'or est
également du cuir du vrai cuir de veau
un peu plus loin au musée comtois
on tient salon à la mode des écrivains
de l'époque brosser des portraits 14
c'est un exercice très à la mode du
théâtre de la danse des ateliers de
fabrication de masques ou de costumes en
carton la citadelle comme au temps de
louis xiv c'est jusqu'à lundi soir
très bien reprenez vos mains